- [David] Hello, readers.
Once upon a time in the previous century,
there lived a cartoonist and
engineer named, Rube Goldberg,
who became well-known for his drawings
of wacky, overcomplicated machines.
This is one such machine,
the self-operating napkin.
You see how it works
is you lift the spoon,
which jerks the string,
which causes the cracker
to leap up into the air,
which distracts the parrot,
and on, and on, and on, and on and on
until finally, you cut the string
which releases this pendulum
attached to the clock,
which has a napkin on the end of it
which swings back and forth repeatedly,
bonking you in the face.
I'm bringing this up
not because I think anyone
should ever build this machine,
it would in fact be extremely dangerous.
You can see that it
contains knives and fire
and a small rocket.
But I want to show you this
in order to demonstrate
a really explicit example
of a cause and effect relationship.
Each object has an effect
on the next object.
And language can be used
in very much the same way.
That's what we're talking
about today, cause and effect.
A cause is why something happens,
and an effect is the result.
So for this machine, the
cigar lighter lights a fuse
which sets off the rocket,
which has a sickle, a kind of knife,
connected to it, which cuts this string.
So why did the rocket take off?
Well, the cigar lighter lit the fuse.
That's the thing that caused it.
What was the effect of the fuse being lit?
The rocket takes off.
But the rocket taking off is its own cause
that causes an additional effect
which is cutting the string.
We can see this very clearly in writing
when an author gives us clue words
about how information is connected.
About how or why things happen in a text.
So with that in mind,
here are some words that signal cause:
Because, since, due to, as a result of.
Whereas here are some
words that signal effect:
So, this is why, consequently,
therefore and led to.
Certainly these aren't
the only words or phrases
that signal cause or effect,
but they are useful ones to look for.
It's important to remember
that cause and effect
doesn't always go left to right.
It's not always gonna be
as straight forward as,
"Because I was tired," cause,
"I took a nap," effect.
Like, it's not always
gonna go cause to effect.
You could just as easily
write that sentence
in the opposite order.
Write, "I took a nap," effect,
"because I was tired," which is the cause.
The nap doesn't cause me to be tired,
I was tired which is why I napped.
You can't just figure this
out by looking at the sentence
in the order the words come in.
You have to think critically
about what you're reading
and consider how the actions
connect to each other.
How does it happen?
Why does it happen?
So let's take this opportunity
to apply this to a text example.
So I'm gonna read this passage
and then I'll try to answer a
couple of questions about it.
So I'll make a couple of
little notes and annotations
as we scribble our way through.
"Fourteen-year-old Michaela DePrince
"sat on the shiny hallway floor
"and tightened the ribbons
on her ballet shoes."
Okay, so she's a ballerina.
"It was 2010 and she was about to dance
"for the chance of a lifetime."
That sounds important.
"An opportunity to earn a scholarship
"to a famous ballet school."
All right, so that's our
chance of a lifetime.
"She was in the finals
"of the world's largest ballet competition
"for young dancers,
Youth America Grand Prix.
"But Michaela was worried.
"She was nursing an injury.
"Michaela understood that
dancing on her injury
"could snap a tendon," ew.
"That could put an end to
all of her hopes and dreams."
A tendon is similar to a muscle,
it helps you move parts of your body.
"Michaela was devoted to ballet.
"She had spent thousands
of hours practicing.
"She had worked incredibly hard
"and had overcome many challenges
to make it to this point,
"so when they called her
on stage, she danced."
And here we have so, which is one of our,
one of the words that we're looking for
that signals that there's a
cause, effect relationship.
So question number one.
Why was Michaela worried?
Michaela "was worried."
We can even do this by
filling out a little form.
Have our little underline.
The cause goes here, the effect goes here.
So what is the cause of that worry?
So in the effect box I'm gonna say, worry.
That's the effect.
But why is Michaela worried?
Well, she was nursing an injury.
And not just that she was injured,
but if she pushed that injury too far
and "snapped a tendon,"
it could, "put an end to all
of her hopes and dreams."
That is extremely serious.
So that injury represents a lot more
than just temporary pain.
It represents a possible, end
to her "hopes and dreams."
So what that injury could
be, its potential outcome,
so its potential effects are
what are causing her to worry.
Another question is why did
she dance despite her injury?
So I'm gonna say that the
effect is that Michaela danced.
And we can see a couple of
explanations in the text, right.
First of all, "they called her on stage."
So she was asked to do it and she danced.
But why did she dance even
though she was injured?
Part of it is that she'd already
"overcome many challenges,"
she "had spent thousands
of hours practicing.
"She had worked incredibly hard."
And also, here was this
opportunity, "of a lifetime."
So even though she was
hurt, she still danced.
And she did it because she
was so, "devoted to ballet"
that she wanted to get
that scholarship to the ballet school.
So I'm gonna say that the cause,
the reason that Michaela danced
even though she was injured
is because the opportunity was so great.
So the opportunity, the
chance to earn a scholarship
to the ballet school, that's the cause,
and the effect of that is
that Michaela chose to dance,
even though she was injured.
And finally, what happened when,
"they called her on stage?"
What did Michaela do?
Well it's right there at the
very end of the paragraph.
"When they called her
on stage, she danced."
What makes this passage challenging
is there's not a lot of clue words
that tell you explicitly,
"Hey this is a cause and
effect relationship."
We've only really got this so.
There aren't other becauses or
therefores or consequentlies.
So we really have to put
it together on our own
to figure out how all
these different events
are related to each other.
And that kind of brings us back
to our old friend, Rube Goldberg.
Because if we're thinking
about cause and effect,
we should be thinking
about all of the downstream effects, too,
because it's possible
to say lifting the spoon
causes the napkin to wipe your face.
Even though there are all
these other stages in between.
But a text won't necessarily spell it out
as plainly as this very silly cartoon.
But I do hope that because
you have watched this video,
you will therefore better
be able to understand
a cause and effect
relationship in writing.
You can learn anything, David out.